he had a Secretary of Homeland Security
Alejandro mayorquez on to talk border
policy because everyone knows it ain't
working but here's mayorkas and his his
very fine eyebrows migrants believe
there's an open border Chris have you
heard some of our political leaders
speak about the Border and communicate
that the border is open I don't think
the more than 1.5 million people who
have been removed or expelled from the
border would consider the Border open
but political leaders
communicate that the border is open that
is music to The Smuggler's ears and the
Smugglers themselves you're going to
blame us all on Republican president
absolutely I mean you're not going to
say that the administration and the
policies on remaining Mexico are title
42 or stopping construction of the wall
that that had no impact Chris that's not
what I said I'm just I'm just citing for
you a few things and please allow me
number one uh they they use that
rhetoric number two we're dealing with
smuggling organizations that are far
more sophisticated than than they were
when I prosecuted them for 12 years as
an assistant United States Attorney and
as the United States Attorney I don't
really care what he said about the
Border can we just talk about his
eyebrows for a second because it's an
interesting thing to have no hair on
your head and all that hair on your
eyebrows I think we should call that the
mayorcus for now on if you see somebody
walking down the street and they're
completely bald but they've got these
just incredible eyebrows that's a
majorcus all right as for the content
look it's just silly like of course he
was trying to blame the Republicans for
everything and when the Republicans were
securing the border and building a wall
and doing all those things they said it
was racist we know that we've had more
border uh border breakages more border
passings illegally in the last year than
I think the last five years combined
like it is just absolutely endless but
as he said there but now that you know
they've got all this new technology it's
so much more complex well are these
Smuggler like are these border Smugglers
are they brighter than us
or are you guys all idiots I think it's
the latter uh anyway it continued uh
majorcus and uh the border is it secure
but when you say it's what does secure
mean to you it certainly doesn't mean
that people aren't able to get across
the border illegally of of course that
is that by that measure the board has
never been secure right
um since the Department of Homeland
Security was created
individuals have invaded so by what
measure is it secure now sir so there
there is not a common definition of that
if one looks at the statutory definition
the literal interpretation of the
statutory language if one person
successfully evades law enforcement at
the border uh then we have breached the
security of the Border oh you
yep I did a lot of them yesterday you
hack you are nothing but a hack yes we
understand that technically
if a million people try to get through a
border and we stop all but one then the
border is not secure because one did get
through but do you think that's really
what we're talking about here you
ridiculous buffoon of course that's not
what we're talking about what was the
number it's about one and a half million
this year was it about one and a half
million something like that about one
and a half million people have illegally
gotten through our border this year we
give them phones we say oh we'll call
you we'll call you in a couple weeks you
want a little cash too here's your Obama
Phone have at it oh you brought a little
fentanyl with you well just ended up to
San Francisco there's always a shortage
up there
foreign
[Music]